environmental activists and developing
nations have criticized the un climate
summit as a failure saying the glasgow
agreement has fallen far short of what's
necessary to prevent a climate
catastrophe
experts believe that despite the pledges
made at cop 26 global warming is still
on track to be much higher than the 1.5
degree celsius limit set in the paris
climate deal in 2015.
not 24 hours earlier cop 26 president
alok sharma was fighting back the tears
the deal was done but with watered-down
amendments from china and india on the
phasing out of coal and the goal of
keeping the 1.5 degree target alive
seeming farther away than ever
on sunday he said the coal giants had to
answer to the smaller island nations at
the forefront of the climate battle
fighting rising sea levels
these are countries on the front line of
climate change
for them you know 1.5
is you know really very bad news two
degrees is a death sentence of course it
matters to them and there was lots of
emotion there um and in terms of uh you
know china and india uh i mean you know
they will on this particular issue have
to explain themselves to developing
countries
the uk prime minister hailed the
agreement but was disappointed it
couldn't go further on coal those
for whom climate change is already a
matter of life and death
who can only stand by as their islands
are submerged their farmland turned to
desert their homes battered by storms
they demanded a high level of ambition
for this summit
and while many of us were willing to go
there
that wasn't true
of everybody
india was not willing to go there
leaving the conference the environment
minister claimed india remained
committed to green energy but his
delegation had rejected the phasing out
of coal insisting the language was
changed to phasing down
the glasgow document however is the
first time that coal has even been
mentioned in a un climate agreement
the un's climate chief said a compromise
on coal beats no deal
regardless of whether you are
an island country or you are a big
country an emerging economy like india
we really need to get everyone on board
the glasgow agreement claims to have
kept the 1.5 goal alive but that might
not be enough for those already living
with the disastrous effects of climate
change
[Applause]
let's take a closer look at this with
lisa bardum who speaks on climate policy
for the german green party welcome to dw
let's talk about india why do you think
india is facing such heavy criticism for
watering down the language on coal when
countries like germany for instance emit
four times as much carbon from coal per
capita as india
so um i think it's the task to reduce
co2 emissions of all countries
but especially uh the big emitters i
mean that's clear
and india could have had a more
constructive role in all of that but i
also
agreed to you
that germany and europe they didn't
deliver so
the role of germany and europe at this
cup was not enough for me
and clearly we cannot get to an
ambitious agreement
in climate politics without those
players and this will be our task for
for the next years right and it does
seem to have been the the big countries
the developed countries like germany and
the us who still seem unwilling to pay
for the environmental damage they've
inflicted on the world for generations
i think uh clearly there's uh there's
been alignment between
the developing countries not paying for
the damages and not taking
responsibilities and the unwillingness
of developing countries to to raise
their ambitions so i think we have to
tackle those two questions
at the same time and still
there's not enough um action be made and
especially the years in europe they
they didn't um
lay enough money on the table
for the topic of adaptation and for the
topic of loss and damage
okay thank you for uh for joining us at
lisa barton from germany's green party
thank you